this week's videos are sponsored by
hello freshmore on them after the
reaction
people hello citizens of the reject
Nation it's me Tera Eric s alongside
this guy Andrew flash Cordon wow we're
watching Rise of the Planet of the Apes
and I haven't seen any of them not a one
have you I've seen one of them
apparently it's the best one the Tim
Burton one from 2001 Tim Burton made a
Planet of the Apes movie what did get
out of here oh my gosh you guys make
sure that you like you comment you also
ring the
bell also thanks to prea for helping us
edit down these videos we appreciate you
so much and we call you super sexy if
you join patreon you get you get sexy
and you get super over there and you can
syn up with your own copy watch the
whole planet of the apes with me and
this guy with the flash with the flash
with the Gordon with the Flash Gordon
also Greg and John offer exclusive
highlights and watch alongs over there
patreon so get with it get ready do you
have any news for the people anything we
should say before we start Flash Gordon
the only thing I know is that James
Franco is in this and that uh Matt
Reeves directed the other two that are
after this the director of the Batman so
I'm looking forward to that once we get
past this one that's all cool lovely
piece of information you know that he's
the info book you guys a little bit you
know it all right we're ready we're
going to watch it in three three two
[Music]
one
cool oh no are they hunting I better not
be I'm not liking the start me neither
no no no no
no no I hate it leave them alone oh my
God I hate
it oh no no had 2 minutes in I'm already
so
sad
oh my
God okay the Rise of the Planet of the
Apes better mean that they rise and they
kill all of those people I was going to
say we humans suck sometimes oh God I
hate it it hurts my heart so
much poor
baby a really don't like that okay I'm
so on the ape side as of right now yeah
me
too which one's this number nine yeah on
the bright eyes color this is
unbelievable oh
wow how many moves was that 20 doc what
you what are you giving her hey give me
that video that was amazing full
cognitive recovery been working on this
for 5 and 1/2 years the date is clear
we're ready St all I need is your
approval for human trial o that never
works out well in movies yes keep your
personal emotions out of it these people
invest in results not dreams here she's
tasking at what is called the Lucas
Tower to move the tower from Peg to Peg
without placing a larger block on top of
a smaller block huh she wasn't able to
complete the puzzle at all we gave her
what we call alz 112 a gene therapy that
allows the brain to create its own cells
wow I need that right we call it the
cure to alzheimer's oh wow this is
giving me some deep deep blue sea Vibes
yeah she's got stage fright is that what
it is although I'd rather give it to
apes and a shark
totally ooh yikes also probably causes
aggression scary know right I'm good I
just quit we're ready to move on to the
next phase uh human trials here you go
BR eyes it's your favorite fizzy soda
come on good girl no no they're going to
can don't do it why
that's
Jesus oh
yeah oh no uhoh the
tranquilizer that's what happens when
you make them smart and it's funny cuz
they're already so intelligent to begin
with yeah there have been absolutely no
side effects associated with 112 oh my
God I hope she breaks into the meeting
first noticed that in chimp 9 hence her
nickname bright eyes you'll see when we
bring her
in yeah bring her in that way is not
going to be good this therapy can be
used to treat a wide range of brain
disorders whoa dang acrobatic we are
confident that you will vote to approve
human Tru
[Music]
trial oh my God oh my God
no oh baby poor
baby why'd you have to go the lethal
route God you know they have freaking
Whatchamacallit put them to sleep drugs
use tranquilize tranquilizer Mr Jacobs I
am begging you these are animals with
personalities with attachments I run a
business
not a petting zoo find the most cost
effective way to put those Apes down oh
God they've taken the 112 Bo of rejected
your proposal they've chosen to advance
other programs start again in molecular
development find a way to get there
before someone else does
Franklin they carry
small suppos been pregnant when we
brought her in she wasn't being
aggressive she was just being protective
oh my gosh uh my brother-in-law works
for security he W me out in a second you
want me to take it home I can't take
care of a monkey he's not a monkey he's
an ape just for a couple days until I
find a sanctuary that's all I need you
started this program bro take the ape
Jacobs made me put down the other 12 oh
my
God I hate it he not going to be able to
do it yeah I'd have too much Humanity in
me to do it how's he
doing well he has good days and bad days
oh
that's
okay so his dad has Alzheimer's that's
why he works on it got it makes sense
why it's so personal to today's the day
right you thought I'd forget you have a
big test today right
chemistry jeez that's sad want to see
something
what oh it's so cute so cute kneel down
damn you imagine what was going through
his mind it's like yes we got the
Breakthrough like not only for just
people in general but his
father no it's that the baby this is
what happens when you become a parent
you never get to sleep
again also too it's probably missing its
mother like crazy
yeah little dude has a
cold my car keys where'd you put them
dad you don't you don't drive anymore
why why don't you feed them can you do
that of course I
can he's so
cute oh my gosh I love him so much if
they would stay that size I would
consider getting an ape but then also
there's the flip side like they deserve
to be in the wild too like H and they
get so big that they could physically
hurt you if they stayed that size and it
wasn't bad to take them out of the wild
I would would consider getting one that
size cuz that might be the cutest thing
I've ever
seen bright
eyes right away Caesar displayed signs
of heightened intelligence wow so I kept
him brought my work home I thought the
other Handler said he was going to find
a sanctuary yeah maybe he decided to
continue his research on him because he
had the he was Advanced also the movie
has to happen too
yeah Caesar was signing up to 24 words
these are my f I love tracking shots
yeah it's a this is a great warer Caesar
was completing puzzles and models
designed for children8 years and
up oh he's going to want out at some
point I maintain my hypothesis that a
the Green in his eyes indicates that the
alz-112 was passed genetically from
mother to son oh love that like how he
drew him green since he's ends up
becoming the Green Goblin and Spider-Man
you knew this was coming Pete and plays
chess pretty well damn I can't even play
chess oh uhoh Sor I can't do this
anymore he belongs in a home there is no
way for him to
live gosh yeah oh thanks yeah it's
Alzheimer's is just now he has to be
pressured with a point to when does he
experiment on his father which is you
know not going to be recommended but
when you're at your Last Resort
right oh yeah I knew it I mean oh you
you I hope I hope it works yeah me too
he might also have like that but what I
thought to be aggression as a side
effect but it may have just been her
protecting her baby so who
knows oh oh Dad got up on his own yeah
what's he doing is he playing the piano
downstairs with that yeah but are there
any side effects right I'm sure there
are there has to
be wow he remembers to play
[Music]
mhm oh he wants to ride a bike oh did
the Chain Break
oh he wants to go play uh it's not the
best idea you're safer in the house
oh
[Music]
no I don't foree you needing more than
one treatment a month something amazing
is that you'll need a blood test and a
scan and the doal we have to be
carefully will he get in trouble though
if they even if it find that it worked
oh yeah I mean absolutely he won't be
able to well where's Caesar I want to
see him can't use the results but yeah
uhoh no I know but not supposed to have
an ape outside Cesar
daddy oh
God no oh my gosh
no enough oh my God doesn't matter with
you I sh that animal anywhere near my
house or my kids again is not dangerous
oh my god dude Jesus effing I told you
not to go out without
us
[Music]
a how bad is it
I don't
[Applause]
know oh I hate seeing them in enclos Ms
like that yeah serve to be free in the
wild going to go see his like take him
to see his it'll be over soon and we can
go get a
treat I'm thinking ice cream oh I see so
Andy Circus is working with her now and
then they work together on The Jungle
Book years later cuz he directed her in
that oh told him to sign handful of
things basic things
what's he saying nothing you're really
hot so when do you think we should come
back well you won't need to come back
the stitches are dissolvable watch out
for signs of infection fever redness
hope for a fever and redness so we can
come back what's she saying now get her
phone number he thinks that you and I
should have dinner together yes he's the
ultimate setup guy I mean look how
adorable he is he's a good wingman
Caesar come on did it work good to see
you again Caroline it worked I'm taking
an ape with me to the next hot vet I
built a pretty good home for Caesar
here now he won't stay this way for long
he's going to soon grow into a large
powerful animal yeah how's he been doing
okay fine I think I love chimpanzees I'm
also afraid of them never
anyone a so cute can we at least give
him some open space I know a place right
across the bridge the Redwoods well the
good thing is the company never knew
about the baby he doesn't need a leash
you'll be fine come on just to be safe
come on come on Caesar probably a good
idea I have never seen an ape on a
leash interesting it's a first thing is
he's probably so strong if he sees
something he's just going to break
there's no way he can like hold it back
true you cannot leave my sight I'll
never find you again what's this what's
she doing do he want to hold your hand
he's asking your permission it's a
suffocating
gesture it's okay come on Caesar off you
go uh oh God how are they going to find
him again I guess he'll come just have
to come back
back he I mean he is in his domain now f
wow cool GNA want to go back to the
house after this as much as he loves
them probably
not whoa that was a cool transition
[Music]
yeah oh
wow he's a fully-fledged adult yeah it's
going to say can he live in the the
house at this age well no I think that's
what she was warning him about that it's
going to become dangerous and probably
Impossible 5 years later but he doesn't
have clothes so maybe so it was three
years originally now five so it's eight
years total so they've been dating for 5
years now long
time it's like I've been replaced what's
going on
buddy it's like look I was your wing man
now you got to find me a woman yeah
right is that that a chimpanzee God if
they let this dog loose and it hurts him
no I don't want it stay
back oh God that's
scary let's go you getting in Cesar damn
he is big you okay
pal you're not a
pet I'm your father yep that's what Dad
means this is where you were born your
mother was here with other chimpanzees
my mother's dead so is mine Caesar it's
okay me too I had no idea that the
effects had been transferred vertically
from his mother but since then he's been
displaying incredible signs of
intelligence I designed the 112 for
repair but Caesar's gone way beyond that
jeez here's his IQ from last year since
then it's doubled my father was gone
this drug brought him back what about
Cesar what do he fit in with us all I'm
saying is this is a good
thing Cesar eat your food
yeah it's hard to eat when you're mad
and
depressed yeah so he's degrading even
with meds I'm wondering well it's it's
been 5 years system has found a way to
fight the 112 virus so that it can't
deliver its therapy oh oh okay father's
disease is going to return with a
Vengeance dang it was a trial run so
well he got a good five years I mean
that's better than nothing yeah I agree
I would sign up for it yeah I'll take
five years over
nothing oh no where's he
going oh Caesar's Gonna Save
him did what who just leaves a door open
on a vehicle like that dude's doing a
car wash but still oh come on
buddy and the keys are in
it oh my goodness okay get out of there
get out of that oh great crazy guy I
said get out of my oh he's going to go
in protective mode yeah that's his
grandfather and also that guy tried
hitting him with a bat years ago yeah he
probably
PTSD this is your problem you
made oh no oh God he can break out of
that window if he really up okay just
stay right there
oh
yep oh ooh
yikes oh
boy woo oh
[Music]
yikes oh you're not outrunning him
no now I'm afraid Caesar's going to
actually kill
him
oo
ouch
daddy oh no okay now he's not going to
be able to live you're going to have to
let him go B to the wild if Animal
Control isn't yeah there's no
way well it was the same thing with the
mom at the beginning was in protective
mode over the baby yep hey
hey take that thing off of
him we take that thing off of him Brian
Cox wow he didn't know he was in this
Cesar going to be okay let's just see
what it's like inside okay yeah I'm
sorry I a no trusting Animal
Control okay looks pretty nice and big
but it's still still we need let him go
to the Wilderness yeah I mean at least
this is closer to the Wilderness than
his room yeah but but he wants to be he
wants to be with his family yeah he
hasn't spent any time with other chips
oh we used to that he'll be a little
skittish at first but we'll integrate
him hey Draco Maloy is it Tom Felton his
name right let's do some paperwork oh
and make sure you lock that door when
you come
in I mean it's it's almost like a
picture he's seeing with him eventually
his dad is going to have to go to at
home too yeah but he's going to freak
out I feel like when he sees that James
Franco is not going to be able to stay
with him
Caesar going to be
okay I don't like it stay here
now why are you leaving me not going
home right
now our experience so long you drag out
the goodbyes the harder it is sign that
later oh jeez there's so many wonderful
human beings in
this
oh like this is what I get for
protecting grandpa just call ahead
before you do God now I'm like they're
doing some weird sneaky that's why
he's like call ahead I don't like it
yeah seriously well that was a odd line
hey down
here yeah he's kept in that
cage stupid monkey oh my God I hate
everyone it makes my stomach
[Applause]
hurt
[Music]
on okay this is tragic so I hate them
all and my stomach hurts now father's
immune system continues to reject the
112 virus rendering the gene therapy
obsolete his health is deteriorating and
the disease is progressing rapidly 10
years you've been running gens this how
many drugs have come down the pipeline
that could save millions of lives the
alz 112 it's like not this again the 112
is dangerous will and it doesn't work I
treated my father with it it does work
worked for 5 years I've already
developed a virus strain that I think
will be more aggressive just let me test
it you're wasting my time like how all
he cares about is the bottom line my
father didn't just recover he improved
you mean increased intelligence it's not
conclusive but yes I want you to start
testing the revised 112 on jimp ASAP you
start talking about Benjamins people
start listening at least if they work
for corporations like you could sell it
as is and be like it's only a 5year fix
again that's still better than nothing
but you're going to have those people
that said you didn't tell me it was only
for 5
years go on don't you know food when you
see it oh my God I hate these people I
cannot wait till the Apes rise and kill
them
all
yeah
now come on everybody do
it
hey I hate it my God I can't wait for
that guy to die immediately clearly it
was tera's favorite character in Harry
Potter oh my God some of these scenes
are so painful I know oh my god really
are they wanted us on the side of Caesar
and the Apes they they've done it
they've done it very well really from
the
top oh that's his window at
home good call
[Music]
a can hear the children
outside tighten your Mas pass me the 113
oh so this is the next evolution of the
drug pressure
steady uh oh he's looking around like he
does not like this and and he's about
to oh oh Franklin get your mask
on got
it oh did he get
affected yeah okay uhoh I feel like that
yeah even just one second of breathing
that in
might
is he the Pariah of the group God I'm
sure he's the alpha and it's going to
teach him a lesson I meant Caesar the
pariaa oh yeah
oh don't rip his clothes off
oh yeah but the advantage Caesar has
over them is he's way more
intelligent
oh like the biting of the
[Music]
fingers
ow she gonna write Jacob that the guy's
name Jacob
Jacobs some one scared me yeah it's the
eyes intelligence results are remarkable
no adverse effects Apes have amazingly
strong immune systems all right keep an
eye on it okay uhoh you got the virus
buddy yeah he's definitely been affected
in some way oh yeah he he definitely has
crap oh this looks like King Lou in
Jungle they're
communicating
yes I
do oh no what the fudge are they doing I
hate these guys so
much no like smart ape okay oh so
pretend to be dumb yeah don't sign in
front of them oh delivering to where
James Franco work I wonder if
Caesar's going to find out because he he
remembers that he worked there cuz he
drove in there and if he can get on
there then he could maybe warn dad about
what's going on or I don't know or do
you think he's going to feel betrayed
that he does this you
hurt show
me GH tell that guy to leave I hate him
sometimes the new kid on the Block gets
picked on that's
yeah yeah I'm taking him out of
here right now not without a court order
you're not he's not yours anymore if I
find out he's been mistreated in any way
I'll have this place shut down I feel
like they're going to mistreat him now
more for like no we're not going home
right now but I'm going to get you out
of here I promise this visit's
over I can't wait for the rise of the
apes to take over I this is like killing
my soul you oh he doesn't even want the
window up anymore he doesn't want to be
oh no oh he feels abandoned oh poor
Cesar well he can now communicate with
the orangutang and build a plan
maybe oh he's going to figure it
out he's like maybe if I let this one
loose fck out right he's looking at the
hardware this this shell be a lot easier
to escape what's his name name is
Cornelia oh my God don't get too close
this one scared me have to death that
big guy is called Maurice I'll show you
something
fun oh my God re oh they got drink
they're having a party here
wow oh God why would he do that that
one's a pain in the ass think he special
or
something uh oh he wants the bottle cap
you saw oh okay yeah yeah
yeah oh he's going to yeah he grabbed it
from his Pock from his pocket I feel
like he saw him do that and that's why
he come on guys let's get out of here I
think he grabbed out of his pocket yeah
I hope so we didn't see it but I assume
they didn't give us that pickup of it
going in there
unless yes ah oh it's a knife got
it see why they don't like smart
Apes oh yeah you let this guy out you've
uh got a golden ticket out of there yep
let Buck Go fullon Buck like uh dude
just do what you
do hey what you met at me I just let you
out oh my
God I was just charging up
oh what is that the
alpha oh you no longer the alpha here
sir oh okay we're all friends fall in
line
buddy you're in
charge I relinquished my power yeah I
have a feeling just from the way Caesar
like scratched off the window like he's
not even going to want to come back to
James Franco anyways oh right I mean
they'll probably have a bonding scene
but he's he's going to want to live in
the wilderness in the wild and just find
that's where he needs to be
anyways it is that just
die yeah looks like it oh
no
hey you know what it it's really sad but
at least he got five extra years with
him it's better than nothing what's
going on here we 113 trials no we have
to analyze koba's Blood Work First
Franklin knows this where is he that's
sick for 2
days ooh he's been sick yeah okay we
agreed to test sparingly on one subject
and that one subject is stunning oh now
he's rushing it oh crap every test
result verifies its effect no more tests
can't rush it we're dealing with a drug
that is worth more than everything else
we are developing
combined you make history I make money
money money money yeah so go upstairs
and deal with the money don't come down
here play with science sir we will
proceed without you yeah you can't leave
all those Apes behind and your research
like
Duck the hell are you oh no I'm
surprised this name didn't
move I can't say our proof they're not
people you know you going to let them go
or not Caesar's not going to want to go
with him though Caesar hey come on nope
he doesn't want to go come on we're
going
home come
On's get out of
here I can't abandon my
brothers
h
ch's training him yeah but it looks like
that but got to get our product
placement see I would just mad scientist
in and like strategically take the
chocolate chips out they're like oh okay
so you want you want a million dollars
for this cookie that now looks like
Swiss
cheese
together strong
[Music]
strong all right get in there
Alpha I'll teach him to be smart D it
Rodney you leave the hose out in the
atrium again what
no oh he saw that number oh yeah that's
a good point he's definitely going to
know the code
great ah good job
buddy like he's coming up with a
complete elaborate plan here that's the
chain he was looking at like when he was
earlier oh it opens the window
wow
ow
he's going to make them smarter cool
he's like I can't make them smart I need
the drug to do it so we were on the
right track like he's going to make them
smart he just needed the drug uhoh
yeah well he's already got it so it
doesn't it's not going to him oh wow
he's just going to like make them all
smart there we go if they're all with
the same intelligence as him that place
is going down oh for sure they know how
to break out form a team get the hell
out of there oh let's go also hopefully
kill this guy oh you are so done
forth okay this is where the phone comes
out and this is turning into a viral
video is this the the scientist that
she's going to did he pass away looks
like blood is on the yeah on the handle
handle
like oh God I I got him imagine the
neighbor I mean sneezed all blood all
over the neighbor too right that's why
I'm like oh if it's a virus I assume
that neighbor could get it
too what the hell I'm not liking his
chances of survival I'm loving the
chances of him dying and I can't wait to
see him yeah sorry Malfoy you might have
survived Harry Potter but not this one
what the hell do you think you're doing
huh wonder if they emptied the guns if
they had access to them that's
it see what you get get back oh God no I
hate it okay come on guys no no
no get him Caesar come on yeah yes take
your stinking BL off me you damn dirty a
here the dirty
one no
yeah
yes he talked get
it does that mean he can talk now for
like fully no more signing I don't
know all right here we go Apes
[Music]
rise yeah yeah you don't got enough
bullets for that
buddy oh
I mean yeah he wasn't like terribly
that's why Caesar was like hey he wasn't
the bad one yeah he was just he was the
he was horrible oh there goes the hose
part yeah you get it now buddy oh water
and electricity don't work well together
somebody's going to get
[Music]
electrocuted later bro oh he's goner
yeah I was going to say water and
electricity don't work well
together
whoa that's such a cool shot that's
awesome Caesar Caroline have You' been
up to Caesar's room oh did Caesar leave
him a no look in the refrigerator
something's missing no one's answering
oh yeah they're going to go there and go
well oh that's a great shot you don't
see that every day
not a good look for his his genis
research but oh and he's finding the
[Music]
evidence what happened she spoke it's
going to say how do I describe
it oh oh God they're in the
trees oh wow that looks amazing like if
someone mowing all these trees from
above
wow that's a great tracking shot the
sfpd tell them we got a fatality what is
it I know where he's
headed yeah yeah oh man this is
just I shall get revenge on my mother
big old repeat of five years ago except
with 50 more was eight eight years right
or eight years ago it was three and then
five plus an
orangutang ah we shall let you all free
Franklin is dead he was exposed to the
113 it does something to people that it
doesn't do to oh okay so it's not good
for humans that's cuz remember he was
like trying to make the strain stronger
so it would last but that obviously is
causing death boy you are not going to
have a good day at work sir for it
now
whoa oh I can't believe he got away
helicopter
okay just with one jump he knocked that
puppy down I mean he's a big boy yeah
all right obviously I don't want any
good human beings Hur right but at the
same time I don't mind all the Apes be
and monkeys being freed right they're
being lit these apes are smer than you
think we've got to kill the leader yeah
I feel like with their intelligence
they're probably not going to try to
harm humans which is maybe why that guy
got out and maybe just try to free their
own
possibly oh God
no ah uh this is not going to well for
the driver he's going to get out okay
yeah this is what we didn't get at the
beginning yeah you you let him out buddy
or you
die okay let him out you're free you're
free all right you can have him I'll go
find a cat
somewhere oh
no they can take those cars I guarantee
they brought one oh smart okay all
right
[Music]
woo oh damn oh
cool yes you are
superior you're on the bridge they're
trying to get to the Redwoods where' she
say they're trying to get to to the
Redwoods oh where he yeah initially took
yeah yeah yeah what's the status of the
mounted units Good To Go sir all right
as soon as I reach you seriously just
let them go there I'm like they're
saying push North but what are they
going to do try to kill him north side
we're going to push them right to
no problem we're ready for them North
side's lock they'll never get through
here God no I hate it just let them go
they're too smart they've got a plan I
hope you okay them I shoot fish in a
barrel good no not good okay there's a
bus right in front of that thing you
don't understand get off this bridge now
this is an evacuation get out all
civilians clear please confirm yeah but
I'm the star of this movie so I can do
what I want yeah maybe James Franco
will'll find a way to help them so they
don't get killed or they take over that
bus yeah I'm I'm hoping like because
there is a Humanity side to Caesar I'm
hoping James Franco can somewhat appeal
to
him although obviously I do want them to
get to the Redwoods yeah just unharmed
all of
them they going to climb up great yes
woo oh that's so cool damn that is high
up it's
great oh oh and Below oh smart love
it oh yes
and they're going to slaughter all right
what can you do to help hey hey
hey be
careful
okay
no no no oh buddy
ow I hate
it yeah get
him oh yeah you better watch out oh no
no no oh I just feel bad for the horse
yeah I know I think Buck will just take
care of
him know take care of him there we go
yeah that's good I'm okay with that it's
the best possible
outcome I he just hitting him nothing
was
happening you
the
no gosh dang
it get the helicopter yeah man or move
quicker and somehow get that helicopter
where are they I can't see them
but they see you I hope
so oh there's a couple big ones yeah
okay the bus that's what I was talking
about before
okay this is great use it as
cover oh
yeah whoa that's awesome so
smart oh just Ram it into them too going
to ram right through hopefully they run
out of bullets don't have time to
[Applause]
reload oh damn yeah surprise attack okay
all
right here we go I was smart that was
smart distract with the boss surprise
attack
oh
no go go go oh my gosh go take down that
helicopter not the machine
gun oh God just mowing them
[Music]
down oh he's going to throw that okay
are you going to be able to hit it wo
[Applause]
yes oh my my gosh Here Comes Buck oh
oh sorry buddy damn yeah oh God you are
so done you are done Zoo but I hope Buck
gets out I don't know if he's going to
oh oh dang dang it sacrifice for the
leader oh poor buddy oh
buddy God so
tragic help me no throw that damn
helicopter in the water
yeah okay Koba
[Music]
yeah
see you yeah but Caesar and James Franco
at least have to have their
[Music]
goodbye
Cesar he's got to say goodbye to him
it's his
dad oh not you
Koba don't touch my dad
boy Cesar's the alpha you got to listen
listen to him back off
buddy that's still his dad at the end of
the day ROM man I'm sorry this is my
fault this has to stop this isn't the
way you know what they're capable of if
you come home I'll protect you this is
his home
now
oh Cesar is
home
that's a great
reaction I love that respect level the
alpha has for him now or the previous
Alpha rather
[Music]
yeah we bow to you
sir that's kind of how we started to in
the jungle
on the jungle wow all right holy tamale
D that was so emotional
too no it was really really good uh I
obviously I was joking earlier when I I
said the I mean I've only seen like I
said earlier I've only seen one apes
film The the Tim Burton one and I was
joking everyone's favorite because I
know everyone talks so much crap about I
didn't hate planed oh ah sorry I'll get
back to it in a sec is this the neighbor
who the bit oh you can see his finger
the neighbor cuz M he was coughed on
yes we know he's been infected and is he
going to be crashing a plane yeah what's
happening blood
uh you got your
comeuppence what does that mean it's
going to spread like to other like the
yeah I feel like cuz he's he's going to
get on the plane and then if he has if
he spreads it other people I mean now
that there's blood on the ground and he
probably will be spreading it Aloha
reject Nation Greg here so many of you
guys know most of my days are a couple
of hours of filming and then most of the
time it's dedicated to like editing and
a bunch of other computer work often
accumulating to like 10 to 12 hours a
day and on top of that comfort food is
like my life's biggest Vice but as many
of you also know working out and getting
healthier has been a massive component
for me this year in particular so in
this Whirlwind I have found myself a
perfect Ally for quick healthy meals
America's number one meal kit a meal kit
that I have subscribed to prior to ever
agreeing and working with them so yes
this is a genuine testimony and that is
of course for hello fresh and hellofresh
isn't just about ease about bringing
health and flavor to your doorstep in
this holiday season forget about the
stress of planning meals for your health
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so hello fresh I'm looking
forward to hosting holiday dinners that
are not only delicious but also cater to
Healthy Lifestyles best part the variety
it is incredible I'm pescatarian so they
have these delicious meals just like
Dijon onion crunch salmon over lemon
broccoli spaghetti and for my more
plant-based days the vegan Maple carrot
power bowls they aren't just meals
they're culinary Adventures I learned
the word culinary during a long day the
last thing I want to do is spend a while
cooking and that's where helloof Fresh's
15minute meals are a LIF saer they're
quick nutritious and Oho tasty perfect
from my non-stop lifestyle so why not
join me in making this holiday season
both health conscious and delicious with
hellofresh with over 45 recipes and
seasonal add-ons to choose from every
week there's always something new to try
and here's something to cheer about go
to hellofresh.com reex free and use code
reject free for free breakfast for life
is that accurate that sounds way too
good to be true there's no way that can
be true go to hellofresh.com reex free
and use code reject free for free
breakfast breakfast for Life One
breakfast item per box as long as your
subscription is active tag your
hellofresh creations with # hellofresh
piic and at hellofresh and let's cook up
some fun and healthiness reject Nation
remember it's America's number one meal
kit well what I was saying earlier is I
didn't I mean I acknowledge it's not a
great film not this is a very good film
I'm talking about the the Tim Burton one
but I didn't hate it as much as everyone
else but also I didn't have the history
that I'm sure many other people
did that being said I really enjoyed
this this film there was such an
emotional attack oh Patrick Doyle he
actually did Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire the music the first three were
John Williams the fifth and sixth were
Nicholas Hooper the seventh and eighth
were Alexander desplat I know everyone
wanted to know that piece of information
but uh obviously the connection I was
making was with Tom Felton who we will
see here in the cast is Draco Maloy the
nicest character we got in this film um
but uh I really did love this film um I
I appreciated the emotional attachment
we got with Caesar just all the Apes and
General I mean I think at least unless
you're a terrible human being I mean
just feeling you know Tom Felton there
you go uh just what the Apes had to go
through just from the very beginning to
just uh in general and then I loved
going through Caesar's journey and then
Andy cir is such an amazing job with the
map as Caesar God he was so good um but
just the journey we went through with
Caesar just from from being a little
baby to you know full-fledged adult uh
it was just it was an emotional
Incredible Journey and I just loved uh
uh just his relationship with James
Franco to then you know getting going to
that awful shelter whatever it was H the
the the ape house or whatever it was um
and then just seeing how treacherous
like seeing what his kind has to go
through and then just gave him a
different Outlook and I also thought it
was interesting too because he had such
Humanity in him um that oh Jak kuto I
believe that Jak kuto was also so Ed was
a mon and baseball monkey movie anyways
um I know I have all these weird facts
in me too many referen too many
references but um yeah I just thought
the the the distinction between like um
what Caesar went through from like he
grew up with humans uh like like a like
a human whereas these Apes like they
grew up as Apes well not as Apes should
in terms of you know just as normal AP
normally without the human without the
human component interactions and then
they got the intelligence whereas he was
born with that so I like seeing that
distinction and then he like technically
taught them and I just thought that was
such a cool twist uh just really good
storytelling but I'll get more into it
what did you think of the I feel like at
the top when they set us up with them in
the cages and us being like Oh we we
hate it so much that we want them to get
out and then finally the reveal at the
end of them actually being back in
nature because in the beginning you kind
kind of have a thought a little bit like
they're being tested on we we really
don't like it but also what's going to
be safest for them because have they has
all of their nature instincts gone away
because they've been in this Zoo they've
been tested on will they be able to
survive in the wild but we see now that
I think in them learning what Caesar
brought with his intelligence that Apes
separate are very weak but Apes together
are very strong that they wouldn't have
been able to survive without that
message which I really like that Caesar
delivered that and I mean the the
medication the medication the virus uh
alz helped him but then also helped all
of them even though it made it it it
turned into a bad
thing which is is not great that it it
spread to humans because he developed it
a little too quickly um which is not
great I I saying on their side I'm like
you guys should have stuck to alz 112
and sold it as a fiveyear remedy instead
of pushing it to be uh 113 and Lasting
forever I don't understand why you could
of course make money off that but again
we are in the reference of of a movie
they had to of course Spirit it that way
of course um and that's the thing with
Corp I mean corporations I mean they're
like What's the bottom line we got to
make as much money as possible and like
so I mean from that perspective yes it
is a movie thing but also too like I
could see a corporation doing what they
did in this film like no no no we're
going to rush it I don't care if it's
like yeah we got the guarantee on the
fiveyear but no we're rushing this right
now I saw how intelligent this thing
rush rush rush ask questions later don't
care about lawsuits or anything of that
matter no rush it don't care about
mistakes so I could totally see that
every opioid company yeah yeah totally
but um I I appreciated like you know a
lot of times when we watch films like
this you don't usually care about the
human characters and obviously there
were some extremely rotten human
characters which is a credit to the
actors I thought they all did a very
good job but there were some human
characters I really did care for I like
James Franco and again it was the
relationship between him and James
Franco having said that already I did
like the personal element that he had
for it wasn't just I want to make money
and I'm a scientist so I'm going to do
no it's his F his father had Alzheimer's
so there was a personal touch here and
why he was doing this and then you know
this ape came into his life and then
there was another personal element to
this uh now you know after he'd lost his
father you know now he was all about
protecting you know his son if you will
so I actually appreciate the the
character elements you had the best of
humanity and then you had the worst of
humanity so again you get the
distinction there of that uh so I I
actually I really like James Franco I
thought he gave a very good performance
in this film and I I like the character
as well and also too I think Caesar is
one of the greatest wingmen of all time
in my opinion like him hooking him up
with one of the hottest veterinarians
I've ever seen ever by the way y um good
looking yeah I mean I didn't I'm not
going to lie they didn't really go too
much into it which is fine um I didn't
care too much about the relationship
which I didn't need to the film's not
really about that um because they didn't
really spend too much time with those
two yeah not a big deal I think the one
line that they did give her which um I
was glad about is that she said
something like not everything is meant
to change uh and she was talking about
the 113 and how like badly it progressed
um but also the same thing like right
after his dad died is when that line
came out of not everything is is meant
to to change and I think that um he uh
obviously sitting there and have learned
that with his 112 being probably the the
fine enough virus to have helped for the
fiveyear uh stent of time would have
helped a lot of people um and uh I also
really like the relationship with John
Lithgow in it because that was the first
time that we saw Caesar being super
protective over a human being because in
the beginning his dad was saying I don't
think he would ever hurt me and his
Veterinary girlfriend I forget her name
forgive
meot um that's good enough was like Hey
listen he's not going to be like this
for long he's going to get larger and
dangerous so I always love it when they
add in a female and she's not stupid so
was very glad about that that none of it
was exposition of just like what is he
doing or why are we here she was only
giving him more information which was
great um but then also uh right after
that we saw Caesar being put into a
position to protect John Lithgow which
was his granddad and then you know sadly
he he died you know shortly after that
while Caesar was being removed from him
but I think Caesar's upbringing and
being protective over the humans that
that brought him up gave him a way of
leading the Apes that was different than
any of the other Apes could have learned
which is why he was able to succeed with
the way that he was taught and trained
even by a scientist which is kind of
built in this movie they're not so good
because they're testing on these animals
and they could be hurting them but there
are some small things that he did learn
from home that he taught to them with
the cookies and the sign language right
ended up um saving them all to be able
to rise so there's there's a bit of a j
position that they put you in between
the azl 112 and 113 although the Apes
would not have been able to break out
and actually rise without it yeah so um
it's like yeah maybe the 113 can can
help the Apes I don't know why we would
need all of the Apes out there to be
super intelligent and be talking that
could pose a danger um but it it does
prove to us to pull the the research
back and not obviously Force the 113
stick with the 112 get to people for 5
years yeah no it's a good point you make
I mean human com compassion and emotion
went a long way especially in Caesar's
case uh obviously too it was so tragic
and sad when he felt like James Franco
just left him there and he felt
abandoned and then you saw him like
cross out the the window uh cuz that was
you know that was a safe place and then
he'd been torn away literally for that
and what he felt like hey I was just
protecting my grandfather what's
happening now and uh then like again uh
now he felt like hey this is my faction
now and now I'm going to protect them
and I really like even though he did
feel abandoned by James Franco which
again totally understandable I get it I
really appreciate that moment when Koba
like was about to attack James Franco at
the very end and even Caesar did
recognize like hey like I still love you
you're still my father you'll always be
my father but this is now my family and
this is now my home even though you and
I will always have that Bond and this
relationship will still like always be
you'll still always be in my heart I
still like I really appreciate that the
writers uh included that moment I I
really would have felt cheapened out if
they never if they didn't give us that
moment yeah and he also did the same
thing um with the uh I was number one so
glad that the blonde guy died with uh a
taser and the water getting a taste of
his own treatment I could not wait for
that that was one of my most favorite
Parts but cecar also implemented the
same um um regard for the brother when
he when he when he puts him in the cage
he interrupts I believe it was Kobo
ready or someone else ready to kill um
the brother like the shy uh attendant of
the of the ape zoo or whatever that he
tells him no we're not killing him he's
been good he's just been doing his job
really and he's not being um he's not
the one torturing exactly and I like
that he brought in his human nature side
of he recognizes human nature a little
bit better than the the other Apes I
think in just growing up with him so he
saved that guy's life which is really
nice um and I don't think he even met he
didn't he was GNA leave the jackass the
blonde jackass from Harry Potter who I
hate he wasn't going to kill him but
that guy killed himself you know like I
mean he was just GNA probably give him
the water treatment but he ended up
electrocuting himself so hey man too
much of an ego narcissist for his own
good that's what you get man you can't
mess with the Apes uh I was really glad
of the the position this put movie put
me in I love it I mean I I give it like
an eight and a half I I I loved it I was
sick to my stomach for a lot of those
parts but they kind of have to put you
in that position to really care really
love um these apes and where we're at
and and the ending was was great and
super Bittersweet and it was really nice
to just see them out in the wild looking
over the city uh to where they came from
um and hopefully they'll be be able to
live in those redwoods safely for at
least for till the next film right uh um
yeah I would probably go like an eight
out of 10 uh the story The the car the
emotional stuff again with Caesar and
James Franco and John litho and all the
other uh Apes uh I really the pacing and
the uh the music by Patrick Doyle the
cinematography appreciated so much of
this film and uh just really good uh
setup for the next film really curious
to see where uh where we go from here
because you totally could end it here
and I'm satisfied but I obviously have
heard how amazing uh the next two films
are uh so I'm curious yeah I'm curious
to see and obviously I'm such a huge fan
of Matt Reeves and the Batman and I know
he directed the next two so I am
extremely anxious to see where we go
from here yeah so leave a like leave a
comment let us know if you want us to
watch the rest of them hopefully they'll
sign us up to do that with you guys that
would be great don't forget to ring the
bell join patreon do all the right
things um we love you guys so much you
got any last words before we get out of
here no just great film uh Andy Circus
seriously that moap job that he did and
and the voice I mean he only had a
couple lines but they were so powerful
they were great they were great awesome
job Bravo we love you guys we love this
film we hope to get to watch the rest of
them and we will see you on the next
one all right John pick a name any name
John here we go you ready for this Chase
Garder Chase Garder yeah my God chase
you know what you know what you're
getting for Christmas this year chase
you are going to get a
fence a nice fence to protect yourself
around Invaders yeah big and tall and to
protect yourself that is also
electrified to protect yourself against
bugs and razor
wire should like you know uh fall out
from the sky or whatever try and climb
over because think about it like this
with a name like Chase Garder you
wouldn't have to run after anyone if
they're just caught on The Wire now yeah
yeah and you get to protect your garden
that's right you can have an electrified
fence around your garden and be
completely self-sufficient and never
share with anybody The Best of Both
Worlds chase people keep coming in
trying to steal your crop so this year
when Santa comes down your chimney with
a giant fence and hour
delaying delivering presents because
he's there for an obnoxious amount of
time and you're wondering like I just
want to get back to my family Santa's
been outside it was exciting at first
but now he's overstaying his welcome
because he's been out there building
this fence and now he's running to the
store to get some supplies he forgot
about but it's hard to find a store open
on Christmas he's really not capable
without the elves wasn't as prepared for
this
fence no as you might he might have
hoped what you don't know about the
Santa Claus story is that he assembles
all gifts on site and so yeah you really
really put a wrench in Christmas he kind
of takes credit for a lot of things he
doesn't quite do you know sure sure so
Merry Christmas Chase Gardner love you
buddy stay stay safe out
[Music]
there